and uh
you know this is something that
with the concussions i tell you know i
can't say it enough i [ __ ] hate when
when you get in front of bulls even on
jackass number two like in the footage
in that that movie i'm just like i'm so
visibly like not okay with it i never
was okay with the bulls and um
with the
you know
all the the butter bean with the the on
your action point like there's been so
many concussions you know who's super
worried about
your uh concussions as dr drew
right i don't know like why he's privy
to like the the extent of your uh
concussion history but he but he's he
seems to be well aware of it and highly
concerned and i think that he
exacerbated my concerns
so
you know i said this to uh to the men's
health reporter i was like you know like
with with uh knoxville's brain
and my dad being
78 years old like
everything my dad says every
conversation i'm like scanning it you
know like like like please god don't let
there be any dementia coming in and i do
the exact same thing with knoxville like
every text every conversation like is
that has
has the concussions [ __ ] up his brain
like you know is he still there
and you and my dad like have uh
you know never never faltered yeah my
brain was [ __ ] up for a while after
the this last one it was for a few
months that um i
it was scrambled yeah i mean dude the
treadmill was nothing compared to that
bullhead and and i had headaches and and
irritability and [ __ ] memory problems
for like three weeks after the treadmill
yeah no i
it was
you know i got all kinds of cognitive
tests and just scored so low on most
every
thing i i the the neurologist is like
did you have trouble paying attention i
was like yeah
you know because i was trying to edit
and i couldn't sit still right and
he's like cause you scored a 17
on the uh attention portion of the
and i was like out of 20 he's like out
of a hundred
[Laughter]
wow yeah so in that
when something i had to go on
antidepressants eventually because it
just started
it just started spiraling downwards and
the antidepressants helped reset my
brain
so uh
and you know time
time helped my brain to heal and recover
wow but uh
didn't mean to bring the show down no
that's okay i'm just gonna smoke a
cigarette during that like when when a
doctor is giving you kind of bad news
like that or bleak news at least like
are you you're able to stay optimistic
or do you get like were you actually
kind of scared like [ __ ] maybe this is
like not gonna get better uh a little
scared but i am pretty much
an optimist so i just have to
believe that i'm gonna get better even
like when i was a kid with asthma i'd be
in and out of the hospital all the time
right
and couldn't breathe have to spend the
night in the hospital
i just kept thinking i'm going this is
going to get better this is going to get
better because it's pretty scary right
when you're a little kid and i almost
died when i was eight um but i just
think
thought like [ __ ] it i'm like everyone
else and i'm just i just gotta get
through this
yeah dude